Alabama
I don't like playing football for the
University of Alabama
an Alabama football player breaks down
in tears after he led cops on a
high-speed chase and was arrested on
charges of marijuana possession
police body camera footage shows
freshman defensive back Tony Mitchell
and his wild traffic stop on March 15th
in Holmes County Florida official state
Mitchell evaded police driving at 141
miles per hour to escape when officers
finally caught up with him and pulled
him over he denied the escape attempt
you didn't just run for me
body camera video then shows the officer
asked Mitchell to place his keys on top
of the car yeah the key ball to the car
the keys to the car yeah
yeah just do me a favor if you don't
mind just put them on top of your roof
so the ignition can't feel it
just set them on top of your roof yeah
just like that
yeah
so the initial won't pick up on it it's
then that the officer asks Mitchell
about marijuana for the first time
from the vehicle
okay so do you have marijuana
because I smell it
are you having a hard time understanding
what I'm saying why just I didn't know
why you was asking me did I have a car
yeah because in Florida they do medical
marijuana cards but in Alabama they
don't it's just something I have to ask
because I smell marijuana coming from
the vehicle all right so here's the deal
as long as you're honest with me I'm
gonna work with you okay but if you're
gonna lie to me I have the right to do a
probable cause search right now
okay
and I do believe you are the vehicle
that just ran from us all right
I'm gonna take your your fob right here
and set it towards the trunk eventually
Mitchell admits there is marijuana in
the vehicle after that officers ask him
to step out of the car
all right man so where's the weed at
now's chance to be honest with me
Foreigner
I didn't learn from you sir because
are you sure about that because there
was two of us there when you passed that
church all right just do me a favor step
out
yeah step out for him body camera video
then shows the officer searching
Mitchell come back here you ain't got
nothing else illegal
that's everything is that everything
all right you ain't got nothing on you
all right put your hands right here for
him I just want to make sure
we'll do me a favor right now you're not
under arrest you are going to be
detained for transplanted bathroom
s
now you ain't under arrest it's gonna be
detained because I just chased that car
as the traffic stop continues it becomes
apparent there's more marijuana in the
vehicle
okay that's more weed
how much weed y'all got
how much more weed y'all got am I gonna
find anything else
how much weed is that
100 grams okay do you have any Firearms
is there where is on the side it's on
the side you have a seal weapon permit
do you have concealed weapons permit
partner do you have concealed weapons
permit
where is it in your wallet well
he said it was on the Patcher that's not
your gun
the gun that's in the car it's not yours
officials later discovered 226 grams of
marijuana seven thousand dollars cash
and a loaded gun in the vehicle
Mitchell's passenger Christopher Lewis
is also taken out of the vehicle when
officers detained both of them Mitchell
begins to cry we put him in the back of
your car okay wait can you put him in
the back of your car and circle him I
ain't under arrest right now
hey it's going to be okay listen you're
just detained okay let's put them back
here
officials speak with Mitchell first and
read him his Miranda rights I just got
to read this to you should start policy
because you're in handcuffs okay I then
Bill Lieutenant here will answer any
questions you may have all right all
right you do have the right to remain
silent choose to give up that right
anything you say can be used against you
and four you have the right to have an
attorney with you prior to during or
after answering any questions after that
Mitchell tells investigators none of the
marijuana is his as he continues to
break down in tears I'm normally a
pretty decent judge of character
right
and you don't have to talk man
I'm sorry nonetheless
foreign
the look on his face when you said gun
told me you didn't know there was a gun
in that car
it's all right man all right man
what's your first name
the original Tony money isn't that in
that car because there's thousands of
dollars I had a thousand I had a
thousand personally all the rest of the
money is
besides a thousand
that's my car like that's a brand new
car that I just got from my recent
birthday okay we can tell it's a new car
and it's fast too we get that
look man here's the thing
we're gonna we're gonna give dude a
chance it's just a step up and say that
future
um
who do the fields belong to the panic
disorder filter those yours or those
kids they're not a controlled substance
I just need to know if those are
actually yours in the description or if
those are his
they're green pills lime green colored
pills they're for like anxiety here
whose shoes are in the back of the car
the black shoes
I had the
the Air Jordans the Nikes and
okay inside those shoes was a bag and
it's got some lime green
Mitchell later tells officers it was
Lewis's idea to quote punch it and speed
off from officers want to ask you a
question yeah and I'm not getting
towards you to support or anything like
that okay I'll just Lieutenant man
yeah I'm not gonna charge you for it
thank you
we all thinking about possibly running
again on me
whenever you turned down Indiana
why'd it take so long to pull over man
but those yours are so like hey was he
driving or was he you I was driving I
wasn't yeah I was driving I
don't know so but like
I was going to say like hey I've never
been in this like situation before and
like with everything yeah he was just
telling me to go and like like so that's
why you just panicked and punched it bro
it's hard I'm not gonna tell her before
okay because you're being honest with me
I will say you outran me like pretty bad
that house I ain't never drove that card
oh is it okay I thought it because man I
could hear you whenever I turned around
Uganda
yeah man I ain't gonna charge you a
pleading loot or anything like that okay
I appreciate your heart yeah I will have
to a car either I might possibly have to
tell it but I ain't gonna seize it okay
um
oh yeah yeah we don't know it it may it
may but but regardless you're still
gonna be able to get it back I'm not
holding it I'm keeping it from you as
the discussion continues Mitchell asks
what will happen if his friend admits to
everything
yeah he did like
only what I believe
it'll be his decision but if he owns up
to it
say that was to having my problem
well because listen we'll go from there
but I can't tell you are under the
influence of marijuana so I will not let
you drive it but we will call your
parents we'd call somebody to come get
you in the vehicle I know that sounds
bad but
I'll be honest man whenever I first
switch
how about that so but we'll check you
out
me a favor let's figure it out I know
you're having a hard time and I and I
understand where you're at but when
officers speak to Lewis they hear a
different story what about the marijuana
that's in the vehicle is that yours or
his uh it's just a passage I just got in
car with my clothes
so you don't know nothing about the
marijuana
what about the firearm
I don't know
y'all know which gun that is
okay because he's saying it's not in his
[Applause]
when officers report this information
back to Mitchell he breaks down once
again unfortunately he's denying I'm not
charging anything with the gun he's
catching the gun charge but he's denying
the marijuana sir okay I swear well
there's life on everything there's
nothing I can do on that okay because it
is a felony I have no discretion of A
felonies with the pills
that's possession of the new drug that's
a misdemeanor I can work with that okay
but I cannot work with a felony stay in
Florida does not allow me to that money
what you mean by that
that much marijuana is a felony in the
state of Florida
okay this possession of marijuana with
intent to distribute y'all have almost a
pound okay
so he's not taking it I tried talking to
him so he's Lieutenant okay
that's all I'm charging sir but I ain't
got a choice sir
please please listen to me sir please
trust me I get it
oh this is the last thing I wanted to do
okay sir
yeah
all right well I'm staying good sit
tight let me talk to Lieutenant
um you should just sit tight for me okay
Mitchell and Lewis were both charged
with possession of marijuana and intent
to sell and or distribute Lewis was also
charged with carrying a concealed
firearm without a permit Mitchell was
suspended from the Alabama football team
after the incident reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie